the feminist fight is is coming to an
end because the product is showing
common sense is winning and data is
winning proving that this is not working
and there's more 60 year old women right
now talking about the biggest mistake
they made is buying into being a
feminist they can no longer have kids
they wish they were married they wish
they would have done this guys I wish
you were right I really do but I spend
probably more time than anything women
under 30. yeah and I I we I say guys
what do you think about this what do you
think about this did these 25 and under
women they they are so far gone and
that's the future I wish you were right
you know you know what it is for for you
to say that you also contribute towards
it though because think about it you're
blaming me no I'm not I'm not I'm not
I'm not I'm not blaming no no I'm not
dumb I'm not blaming you there's an
element of it that even you know
whatever you want to change you have to
look at it in a different way and not
capitalize off what's out there